people will he'll know what a bump is
probably not everyone's like coke no but
everyone me too
it's like when a famous person walks
into the comedy club and they get to go
on before you yeah it got bumped by a
Jeremy Piven the other night oh that's
gotta hurt now it feels good yeah that
does happen to like there's someone
famous in the crowd and you're like damn
I do this for me and then the second you
see them and they're like I'm playing
the hits yeah what's up everybody
welcome to stupid questions I'm stupid
Chris two-step for now I'm here with my
man Sam Morril what you got a good
bombing story I always like to ask
comics a good bombing ever hot man oh
yeah I was in Bridgeport Connecticut and
it's going like pretty rough first 20
minutes or so there's I search for it
there's a guy who's just heckling me
every other joke I just said dude shut
up
no one gives a about your stupid
additions to my jokes yeah shut up shut
your mouth and ink gets up and I'm like
this is the biggest dude I've ever seen
really starts walking toward the stage
I'm like they're not paying me enough
for this so I'm out of here
so what you don't walked offstage to
booze I go in the green room it's a
cordless mic I'm still holding the mic
and he's banging on the door just like
one woman they were doing security he
finally leaves I go back out and I do
another 30 minutes and then one guy why
did I get my rhythm back yells he's
waiting outside for you you know you're
doing a shitty gig when you have to plan
an escape route yeah from the stage
here's stupid question what gives you a
bigger sense of accomplishment clipping
your fingernails or picking your boogers
clipping nails cuz that means that means
I'm a they got long enough for me to
actually yeah I've anxiety I bite my
nails all same-same what me bite them
off they're disgusting it's not a cool
no it's not a good tick speaking of
ticks there was a guy I just did a
comedy club and the guy had a tick who
owned the club he always says Mamma Mia
every time he was like Mamma Mia Mamma
Mia he kept saying Mamma Mia and I was
like what's going on he's like oh I have
a tick I can't control him on me and I
just kept saying mom and me and nobody
gets drunk
it gets even crazier he's just he can't
say anything about Mamma Mia that'd be
great if the doctor fixed it and now all
I can say is Mamma Mia to mommy that's
always good
oh here's a stupid question you could be
any vegetable what vegetable would you
be
Terry Schiavo no I would be I would be I
think of I would be a pickle you would
be pickle cuz they were allowed in a lot
of different environments yeah they're a
versatile veggie yeah I think I get to
be zucchini or maybe a carrot you
Garrett so kind of there another like
VIP vegetable you'll see him in like
drinks yeah get him in cake
dude you're good-looking guys they
really told you that absolutely you are
really mean that yeah I do
I got ecstasy you got dude thanks for
doing stupid questions now you get a
stupid gift and because you're special
is so dope positive influence
I got you multiple gifts most people get
one gift I got you multiple gifts cuz
you crush I can't really here we go
so we know you're a big New York Knicks
guy but they're not a sponsor so we got
you orange shorts Knicks colors then we
got like this is like it's a youth large
because you have little baby bishops
socks yeah we got these are about 99
cents for a 30-pack um we got you a
Jersey that says Knicks and Ewing but
neither our sponsor can't sue because
it's not that and then finally just to
make you nauseous frame picture of Joe
Max Oh God
go look up this nut did you have a good
time on this I had a great time yeah I
know Macke you know maybe put a damper
on it but hey it's been great
you